ومن الرياض ينضم الينا اختصاص الوقايه من
المخدرات عضو مجلس اداره المشروع الوطني
للوقايه من المخدرات نبراس الدكتور سليمان
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض حياك الله
يعني
الحساب مكافحه المخدرات كما نشاهد نشيط
جدا خلال هذه الايام
حمله كبيره للقضاء على الشبو في السعوديه
انتم في نبراس ما هو دوركم في في هذا
الموضوع وكذلك ما الذي تقومون به تجاه
الاسر تجاه الطلاب ايضا كذلك بما انكم
منصه توعويه الى حد ما طيب اهلا وسهلا
واهلا وسهلا مشاهدين بدايه اكرر يعني
سعاده الغامره بجهود رجال الامن البواسل
يعني في محاربه كافه انواع المخدرات ومنها
ماده الشبو لا الحمد لله منا نشهد يعني
انجازات عظيمه في هذا الصدد اليوم
في يعني من اهم وسائل الحمايه من
التعاطي المخدرات بشكل كامل هو خفض الطلب
وخفض العرض الجهود الامنيه تهتم بخفض
العرض يعني في هذا الجانب ونشهد كما جهد
جباره في هذا الجانب الاهم والاقوى وكما
توصي المنظمات الدوليه
الابرز والاكثر
اهميه هو خفض الطلب وهو الوقايه من تعاطي
المخدرات وجعل الافراد قادرين باذن الله
عز وجل على كسب الحصانه تجاه هذه الافه
والبعد عنها قدر الامكان تعادل مخدرات هي
عارفه تعم جامع جميع الشعوب العالم
لا يستثنى منها احد لكن كيف نحمي انفسنا
وابنائنا منها هذا هو يعني هدف المشروع
الوطني للوقايه المخدرات نبراز
بتعزيز يعني المساهمه بتعزيز المجتمع
اتجاه هذه
الافه وكيف وايش اللي قدمه يا دكتور
البرنامج في انه
للاسر في انهم يتعاملوا مع افراد العائله
سواء للافراد العائله المتعاطين لا سمح
الله او كذلك محاوله المحافظه عليهم
الوقايه ايضا كذلك من
انخراط في مثل هذه المواد المخدر القاتله
طيب النقطه
اهم اليوم هي المرحله ما قبل التعاطي وهذه
اغلب جهودنا مركز على هذا الجانب رقم
الجهود الموجوده في كل الجوانب مرحله ما
قبل التعاطي هي تعزيز حصانه الانسان او
الطفل تحديده والابناء تجاه هذه المخدرات
وعدم ورفضها وعدم حتى مجرد التفكير
بتعاطيها من خلال اعداد برامج ووسائل
ومواد علميه وايضا
بودكاستات وغيرها والعاب وغيرها مكرسه
لجانبين تعزيز مهارات الوالدين تجاه تعاطي
المخدرات وكيفيه حمايه ابنائهم من تعاطيها
وذلك من خلال
يعني غرسيه يعني قيمه لدى الاباء ان تعاطي
الوقايه من تعاطي المخدرات تكون من خلال
تنميه فرد سوي على جميع المستويات اليوم
الوقايه من تعاطي المخدرات ليست من خلال
تقديم ماده وهذه عينه يا ابني شوف هذه ما
ينصح تتعاطاها لا مو بالطريقه هذه فقط
الطريقه يعني دكتور تغيرت تطورت طرق
التوعيه تجارب الدراسات العلميه وايضا
توصيات المنظمه الدوريه في هذا الجانب تحث
على ان نركز على التنشئه
والتربيه السويه اولا
تنميه المهارات الحياتيه لا دعمنا تعزيز
قدرتهم على اتخاذ القرار اليوم لما يتعاطى
الواحد تسال الناس اللي متعاطين تقول ليش
تتعاطى يقول لك والله اغصبوني اصدقاء انا
اخذها بمصطلح عامي اضغطوا عليها اصدقائي
قلت بجرب هذه معناتها ان الشخص عنده ضعف
في اتخاذ القرار
والدفاعيه لكن يا دكتور يعني
مصداقة لكلامك ايضا في في هذا الخصوص يعني
اليوم في انتشار
لماده الشبو طبعا هذا من خلال ما كشفت عنه
مكافحه المخدرات بالاطاحه على مروجين 24
كيلو ونتكلم غرام الماده التشبو في
المنطقه الشرقيه وغيرها من المناطق والسبب
انتشار هذه الماده خصوصا بين المراهقين
طبعا
ضعف الوعي بخطوره هالماده قاد الى التوجه
كثير من المتعاطين الى تعاطيه هاي يمكن
هذا احد الاسباب والعوامل ايضا عدم
الادراك يعني بعض الناس لما تجي تقول له
مخدرات وماده تصنفها بعنوانها بعنوان صحيح
يخاف منها لكن لما تاتي بمصطلحات من خلال
جلسات بعض الاصدقاء وضعف قدره انسان زي مع
اسلفت انه على تعاطيها هنا يكون خلل اليوم
قد تكون ماده مثل الشبو لكن ممكن لا قدر
الله مستقبل تظهر مواد اخرى في عالم
المخدرات مصنعي وعصابات المخدرات كل يوم
تظهر تصنع ماده جديده وتحاول ان تغسل
المجتمعات فيها فهدفنا من خلال برنامج
تحديدا انه نعزل الحصان مجتمعيه اتجاه
جميع المواد بما فيها الشبوه وغيرها من
المواد ايضا من خلال بعض البرامج المختصه
بمناقشه الافكار المغلوطه يعني من خلال
منصه التواصل الاجتماعي عندنا موجود حلقات
خاصه لمناقشه بعض الافكار اللي تروج لبعض
المواد المخدره اشكرك جزيل الشكر الدكتور
سليمان للحدان اختصاص الوقايه من المخدرات
التي اداره المشروع الوطني للوقايه من
المخدرات شكرا جزيلا لك
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات